hey guys is dense the powder thick here
oh and i'm david griffin yours in the
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield
episode 18 yeah providence so this is
kind of almost like it's not a
two-parter but it's kind of like the
second part to last the week before ya
episode it's all this Hydra aftermath
stuff captain america to aftermath stuff
about shield collapsing because of Hydra
infiltration so I have to start off I
like this episode I mean I I think
agents of shield is slowly improving
it's not the best show on television but
it's getting better I enjoy it is it a
show that I'm like dying to see every
week no but I don't mind seeing I think
it's a lot more fun now for me I think
because I like the fact that ward it was
a bad guy now his character is much more
interesting I love Bill Paxton as this
clairvoyant character and I think the
shield team now has a purpose in a
mission that I can kind of empathize
with and see like ok they're they're
gonna go you know they want to reform
shield or you know stick to what what
shield was about right and this is like
a way for them to do it yeah what about
you I I think the show's losing steam
since the captain america episode after
that i think it's it's still better than
it was in the beginning but i think it
start it's still holding on to that
story arc again you know we get to see
patton oswalt in this episode at that
new base i discovered a new hit hidden
base instead like you know Furies not
dead he's actually live we don't tell
anybody it's like again it's still it's
just so heavy it's so heavily reliant on
the movie and I think it's just it still
gets to make something like man like are
you your own show like could you
function outside of them are of the
captain america looks like it didn't
even really get good until then and then
it's now so not for me not keeping up
every week it's just getting better and
better i do love bill packs i think he's
a great actor I think he like you know I
think micros and he steals every scene
and they agreed i think he does steal
every scene that he's in i like this you
know reveal to the oath what they called
a woman in the flower dress that who was
you know kind of shocked by that she was
like oh i thought the third one would
have been some kind of mythical like
Creech something like you know bigger
than just like a guy with you know
high-level security access he's good
I something the show overall is losing
steam from the captain america aftermath
so you have to disagree I don't think it
does i don't think i don't think the
show needs like before when we're
talking about these episodic episodes in
the beginning of agents of shield where
they'll always make these references to
the Avengers or Iron Man or four blah
blah blah like Timmy that was like ok
they're trying to bank on these things
but I think that that because the
captain america storyline is so
entangled with shield that it only makes
sense and i think it has it's not that
it has to rely on it it's that this
story is so big in the Marvel Senate
like universe that it has to it has no
choice it has to adhere to it and so for
me I don't think that's a weakness i
think i think actually it's a strength
because it actually is a storyline that
that fits into what shield is about
versus before where they would be like
oh here's an Asgardian that visits are
like we're given with a sip episode it's
just like hell here's a sip from Asgard
a one-off in prayer doesn't really have
anything to do the storyline where this
one I feel like it does have something
to do with our characters yeah I just
wish they got I was just to get down to
it I wish I got the spy espionage stuff
down better yeah I think Captain America
obviously did a much better job this is
again maybe unfair comparisons is
different subject matter I think there's
a show on FX called the Americans the
bus some undercover Soviets and living
in America I think that does it much I
wish they'd get this the Espionage spy
stuff better just I don't get the weight
behind everything I don't feel like why
is this important in it if I never saw
the captain america movie i wonder
people who i'm sure some people watch us
who haven't seen it maybe knobs are me
sure ninety percent of people have seen
cats bregma if you haven't seen captain
American you're watching this episode
was it still as impactful for you as if
you hadn't but yeah I just don't I'm not
as pleased with the spy espionage stuff
but bill paxton i agree i think he's an
excellent addition and i'm glad i hope
they give him a longer runks i would
like to see more poker i think so i
think they need to yeah he's great I
think easy he's one of the best
additions on the show and it gives it
night he's a good villain it's davillon
I can like be like okay like I line I
want to see that villain and I like
Ward's turn is is like it's like the one
thing I am worried about though is what
we're talking about in previous episode
or reviews to about Ward doing this
whole well I actually do care about them
thing like Oh skies the 12 easier and so
cheesy too I don't want that i want him
to be a bad guy yeah yeah like they're
trying to go like oh he's conflicted
like no and then eventually he he turns
it on Bill Paxton because of his love
for sky nun and a best thing to do make
him a bad guy yeah sure he probably
should have some reservations about what
he's doing yeah but ultimately I want to
see him is like okay like maybe like
they do kill off bill paxton in the
future his character Garrett right let's
say they kill off his character and
maybe Ward gets pissed off by that and
he becomes the main villain right of the
entire series i'd like to see something
like that yeah i mean we're getting
towards the end so i wonder where
they're gonna go like I wonder where
they're gonna end this because I mean
this show yeah I mean it's I don't know
it's gonna get renewed has been
announced yet so I mean I wonder how
they're gonna if wrap up the season or
if it's gonna be an open-ended you know
episode at the end I wonder how it's
going to end up alright and so at the
end we have garrett in war they go to
the fridge because they want to break
out the prisoners and get some weapons
so we get to see you know we get to see
that the Berserker staff they get the
serger staff they get that thing from
Peru like oh that gun or whatever weapon
so it loosely connected with previous
episodes but I think the main thing was
it was when when Ward tells Garrett no
no trust me there's something else down
here below and then they get well when
they break out Quinn they basically give
the the Gravitron right yeah damn it to
hell yeah so I'd like to see now like
all these pieces that we saw in previous
episodes your stolen yeah they are still
pulling together so I kind of like
seeing that as well yeah I mean it
wasn't mean they are like I said I'd to
give her credit the show is better than
it used to be it is pulling things from
other episode so now we're building it
just it just took a long time yes the
23rd season taking a long took a long
time to get here but it is slowly good
they should have started in January
that's what I I think they should have
started 13 episodes maybe and built to
cut the captain america
maybe six or seven episodes right and
then did Captain America's i think it
was like 16 or 17 episodes too it's only
of the American I don't know yeah
there's a lot of filler in there right
do those six have Captain America I bet
you the show would be out doing a lot
better oh definitely I think the ratings
would be better and I need just be a
stronger show overall yeah definitely
but but I like where they're heading I
mean obviously they still need a lot a
lot of improvement yeah but I i I'm here
at least till the end of this season
yeah I'm definitely here for the end of
the season we'll see if it gets renewed
or not but i'll see how see how it all
ends alright alright guys so you can
post your comments below on the website
pink hair or calm or on our youtube
channel think here I'll pro make sure to
subscribe to that ome sure also to check
us out on twitter from talk to destin I
about how you like an agent of shield
are you still watching it if not less so
we think with all the captain america
tions we're at think hero i'm at griffin
de and we also a Facebook page that's
facebook com / think hero fans and make
sure you like that page and share our
videos on Twitter and Facebook and other
social media
you